[Applause]
he is the oscar and golden globe
award-winning actor whose new book is
called green lights matthew mcconaughey
hey how are you doing bill good to see
you thanks for having me
how you doing thank you for doing this
uh your book is
fascinating i tell you for a guy who for
so long
was known as you know a beach bum who
didn't own a shirt
you're a very deep guy you really are
so why don't you just start off by
telling people what that
title means because i think it's
important of the book
yeah so i've been keeping a diary for 36
years
and i finally got the courage to take
those diaries away to go see what they
were
what i found in 36 years of writings
were stories people places prescribes
poems prayers and a whole lot of bumper
stickers
then i looked at those and i found this
central theme of green lights i found
that i had caught green lights in my
life the green lights are things that we
we like they give us freedom they say go
they affirm our way
i found that i had created a lot of
those in my life by choices i made i
found that in a lot of ways
they were thrown in my lap and i got
very fortunate and lucky
and did good things with them i also
found that a lot of the yellow and red
lights in my life
crisis hardships death of my father
years abroad where i was lost
had green light assets in them that
revealed themselves
later in life now when we realize that
there's a green light asset in a red or
yellow light in our life is sort of
relative sometimes we notice it in the
moment
sometimes you'll notice that next week
next week sometimes we notice it on our
deathbed
but i do believe that eventually in the
rearview mirror life all the green all
the yellow and red lights do eventually
turn
green well
boy you got that down um
yeah and i mean so much of the book
honestly it it do you remember that old
dos equis maybe it's still on commercial
the most interesting man in the world
yeah yeah yeah
that i mean so many of the passengers
are like copy
for the next most interesting man in the
world he he smoked peyote in mexico
in a cage with a mountain lion you did
that you were blackmailed into having
sex at 15.
how does that even happen i would have
been the blackmailer
at 15. do you want to tell that story
as i wrote as i wrote in the book and i
didn't give a whole lot of details on
that you know i was raised thinking i
wasn't going to lose my virginity until
i was married and at least if i did it
was going to be with someone that i had
a really good relationship with
well neither of those happened this girl
was much older
and as i write in the book i said i was
very sure at the time
that i was going to hell for the act and
now i i merely
hope that that is not the case uh i'm
nearly sure that i hope that's not the
case
yes you're you are a philosopher that's
that's the interesting part and and you
did something
in your career that is very rare which
is you change
the perception of yourself that's the
hardest thing to do
in show business you know when you get a
label on you
it sticks and you manage to find a way
to not be the beach bum with the shirt
off
you know to be this guy you want to tell
the kids how to do that
well what happened was i was the rom-com
guy
i was the shirtless guy on the beach um
that was fine
yes i said it then i'll say it now those
rom-coms i was doing were paying the
rent for the houses on the beach where i
was shirtless
thank guilty um well i never
you know that part but i did notice that
that's all that i was in the public eye
and that's all i was
to studio finances in hollywood other
roles i wanted to do dramatic roles that
they were not being
offered they were not an option for me
so at a time where i said
if i can't do what i want to do i'm
going to stop doing what i've been doing
it was a scary proposition so i checked
with my wife
check with my money manager and agent
and said i'm going to stop doing
rom-coms well
guess what um okay that's all that came
in for six months
i got a 14.5 million dollar offer for
one and that was harder to say no to
because i got a little relative on that
going really you're going to say no to
this which i finally
did and then for 14 months after that
nothing came in call my agent goes no no
one's even mentioned your name
so a 20-month sabbatical after 20 months
of a sabbatical from hollywood
being gone not seeing me shirtless on
the beach not seeing me in your living
room or in a theater in a rom-com
i became a new good idea where's
mcconaughey been
we forgot about it well guess who's a
good idea now for lincoln lawyer
killer joe paperboy mud true detective
dallas fires
uh magic mike right and i guess so that
that movie uh
that one you turned down for 14.5 uh
what was it and who did it
i'm not telling and it didn't get it
didn't get made okay um all right so
the other reason i think you were able
to do it is you just have uh
an innate likability which is
rare but you know usually carries the
day it's interesting you talk about
your big breakthrough time to kill the
other guy who was up for it
was uh the other actor i think in your
generation
who has the only one who has the same
amount of likeability which is
our friend from another mother brother
from another mother well
you know you're both sons of texas you
have this weird
family history which i'll get into in a
minute but um
you're sure he's not your real brother
it's still debatable
we're still finding out my mom's got a
story that makes us both think
we just might be related
you